e aí
o número um vídeo se despe tombadilho
tinir de ferros estalar do açoite
legiões de homens negros como a noite
horrendos a dançar negras mulheres
levantando as tetas magras crianças
cujas bocas pretas rega o sangue das
mães vamos moças mais luas assustadas
não estão milhão de espectros arrastadas
em ânsia e mágoa de bens os raios vão
ter irão outros enlouquecem outros que
de mártires embrutecem choram dançam
alice engraçados que serve vós senhor
deus que loucura se é verdade tanto
horror perante os céus quem são estes
desgraçados
eu não encontro e foi isso mais que o
rir calmo da turba dígitos severa musa
musa libérrima audaz são os filhos do
deserto onde a terra esposa a luz ontem
vão em campo aberto as tribos de homens
nus homens fortes bravos hoje míseros
escravos sem ar sem luz sem razão para
subir a caravana onde a vista na cabana
cima da noite nos belos a deusa choça do
mundo a deus palmeira das fontes adeus
amores a deus senhor deus dos
desgraçados dizei-me vós senhor deus que
loucura se é verdade doutor o fera dos
céus o mar por que não apagas de cruz
vaga de teu manto este borrão astros
noites tempestades aids
e vai os mares tufão mas existe um povo
que a bandeira empresta para cobrir
tanta infâmia e covardia deixa
transformar-se nessa festa e mantém tudo
que passou que queria meu deus meu deus
mas que bandeira é essa e prudente na
gávea tripudia auriverde pendão da minha
terra que a brisa do brasil beija e
balança roto na batalha que se visa a um
povo de mortalha mas tá insônia demais a
etérea plaga levantai-vos heróis do novo
mundo andrada arranca esse pendão dos
ares salombo fecha as portas dos teus
mares ii
e como anda na sua comunidade o
movimento de rua
e vamos falar do alto do moura enquanto
protagonista do movimento de rua chamado
seresta seresta na ladeira do alto do
moura sim porque o alto do moura ele não
faz jus apenas ao título por conta da
gastronomia e principalmente da arte do
barro mas também posso sua poesia com
sua música e como tal não poderia deixar
de ter em suas ladeiras uma seresta
é uma seresta que normalmente é
associada ao romântico nada contra o
romântico muito pelo contrário mas essa
seresta ela é luta
e ele é resgate e mantença de uma
identidade de um povo
a e lá naquele território demarcado que
a gente tenta dar voz ao povo a gente
tenta manter a tradição
eu achei que oportuniza um microfone
para aqueles que tem algo para falar e
todos nós temos algo para falar
e às vezes precisa só de uma
oportunidade essa seresta ela foi
inspirada no movimento também diferente
o que acontece em olinda onde uma
senhora de mais de 70 anos
o e satisfeita com um movimento violento
naquele patrimônio da humanidade com
acesso de carros de auto porta em sua
geladeiras você vai ideia de tomar rua
no início da noite tocando seu violino
é isso já demonstra aqui para que a
gente toma uma atitude enquanto
compromisso com a arte precisa ter dado
certa qualquer idade serve
e essa despertou com 60 anos
bom então ela tomou as ruas naquela
noite mostrando a insatisfação de como
poder público estava cuidando daquele
património da humanidade
a massa as pessoas identificar o tanto
com aquele movimento que resolveram
resolveram aderir de uma maneira
permanente é tomando as ruas das
ladeiras de olinda todas as
sextas-feiras de maneira que hoje faz
parte da grade da prefeitura como
movimento cultural integrante do
património histórico olinda
bom então assim a gente tá colocando
esse movimento nas ruas do alto do moura
e foi assim inspiração
bom então é hoje
e essa tarde dificilmente a gente vai
sair igual que a gente entrou a gente
era como a gente está sendo vamos
renovar nossas ideias nossas conceitos
nossas concepções porque não se concebe
né que profissionais da área da educação
não estenda seu olhar para um movimento
cultural de rua esse movimento que
necessita do apoio do estímulo e o nosso
compromisso enquanto cidadão enquanto
educador que de temos esses jovens em
algum momento do nosso dia
é importante que a gente leva essa
mensagem
e é muito importante que a gente
aproveite esse diálogo que esse diálogo
extrapola o que tá posto enquanto a
educação
bom então cabinda carros hoje
e o movimento de rua que tá acontecendo
na sua cidade
é o melhor qual o movimento de rua que
está acontecendo na sua comunidade se a
gente sabe e não apoia o frequenta é
grave
um pincel gente não sabe é gravíssimo
é porque esse não saber
o que significa omissão a omissão que
está muito próxima
a alienação
é do monstro chamada alienação
o que alimenta a operação
e às vezes a gente pensa que o pequeno e
simples movimento de rua não tem valor
não merece o nosso tempo
e merece sim chega de omissão chega de
achar que movimentos
e enormes que tem uma visibilidade e que
vale a pena a gente parar para observar
e participar
é porque não existe cultura pequeno
grande existe cultura então da mesma
maneira que temos que valorizar uma
cultura que requer uma ampla estrutura
e a gente precisa também valorizar
aquele pequeno movimento que ocorre
nosso bairro
é porque a lista embutido o lazer a
cultura a preservação da identidade de
um povo
e aí a seresta ela integra e números de
valores não é só cantar
é respeitar é ter oportunidade de pegar
o microfone e falar falar algo que
contribua para uma melhora na sociedade
nós temos esse compromisso enquanto
cidadão
não vai não vai eu sempre escuto cultura
serve para quê
é o que vale advogado médico dentista
não gente o artista ele precisa do olhar
sensível da sociedade a todo esforço a
todo uma luta por trás desses movimentos
por mais simples que seja
é mas para que a gente possa se
aproximar a gente precisa
a abertura a gente precisa se despir que
no caso aqui eu trago o meu pé no
o que é uma forma de mostrar que a gente
tem que se desvencilhar do que o
capitalismo nos impõe essa cultura das
micro tecnologias ela tem engolido
nossas crianças
e nós pais muitas muitas vezes
e preferimos levar nossos filhos no
shopping
a adquirir com maior sacrifício no
celular do que mostrar ele o movimento
hip hop o movimento do bumba-meu-boi o
artesão do alto do moura
e o que é brincar o que é manusear o que
é estimular a criatividade com pedaço de
barra chega essa postura não leva a
lugar nenhum
o e enquanto educadores é fundamental
porque a gente pode utilizar toda mídia
outdoor televisão jornal panfletar mas
toda base toda estrutura
em toda toda postura citadina ela inicia
e na escola obviamente que a família tem
o papel mas se aqueles pais tiveram uma
valoração na escola
e ele tem mais capacidade de repassar
isso
é importantíssimo essa aula de artes
hoje há uma tendência generalizada de
não valorizar não não podem me ajudar
ele tem um compromisso enquanto cidadão
de resgatado e manter a nossa cultura
que ela nossa história
e as experiências quilombolas as
experiências dos índios
a mostra que já que nós temos toda essa
miscigenação que a gente tem que dar
quando eu continuidade de valorizar mas
cada vez mais
e colocar mesmo como prioridade
e é preciso que a gente roupa o excesso
de lucidez
e é preciso sonhar
a sonhar com um mundo novo mundo melhor
a sonhar com essa efetiva possibilidade
a utilizar assim a tecnologia obviamente
que é um recurso importantíssimo mas nós
temos que sermos maiores
e a humanidade o ser ele tem que estar
acima estou sentindo uma clareza tão
grande
o que me anula enquanto pessoa comum e
atual
e é uma lucidez vazia
e como explicar assim como cálculo
matemático perfeito no qual no entanto
não se precisa
eu estou por assim dizer vendo
claramente o vazio e não entendo o que
entendo pois estou infinitamente maior
que eu mesma e não me alcança
e aí também que essa lucidez pode-se
tornar o inferno mano
ah pois sei que em termos de nossa
diária e permanente acomodação e resig
nada a essa realidade
e é um risco
[Música]
e apagar e pois deus essa minha flagra
e ela não me serve para viver os dias
e ajudai-me a de novo consistir de modos
possíveis
e eu existo eu consisto eu consisto amém
e aí